humains entreprises antidote handicap
vision challenge en vie qu'est-ce que
vous inspirent ces mots quel lien il y
at-il entre chacun d'entre eux eh bien
c'est ce que je suis venu vous faire
découvrir maintenant depuis toujours
sensibilisés au handicap dans mon
enfance puis dans le cadre de ma
carrière professionnelle
j'ai été douze ans référent handicap
puis ces quatre dernières années
responsable commercial de deux
entreprises adaptées je peux dire que je
connais bien le monde du handicap
et pourtant dans mes dernières fonctions
j'ai souhaité recruter un jeune
commercial
arthur arthur
je pensais qu'il était handicapé au
niveau du bras droit puisqu'il portait
une attelle en fait il est amputé au
niveau de la jambe gauche
tout le monde en rigole encore tout ça
pour vous dire que nous avons tous
beaucoup de travail encore à accomplir
par rapport au handicap
un constat avez vous remarqué que dans
le monde dans lequel nous vivons
il n'est pas adapté mais pas du tout
adaptés aux différents handicaps
imaginez-vous en fauteuil roulant avec
une déficience auditive ou visuelle pour
aller faire du shopping ou dîner au
restaurant
avez vous déjà vu une carte de
restaurant en braille un serveur une
serveuse pratiquer la langue des signes
et je ne vous parle volontairement que d
un handicap que tout le monde connaît ce
que je veux vous dire ce soir c'est que
nous sommes tous tous potentiellement en
situation de handicap
il y a quatre
un constat cinq cent mille demandeurs
d'emploi sont en situation de handicap
le taux de chômage des personnes en
situation de handicap et 20% supérieur
aux personnes valides
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
ce soir je souhaite vous parler d'un
modèle économique
l'entreprise adaptée il y en a un peu
moins de 800 en france qui emploie
trente cinq mille personnes en situation
de handicap
alors que pour moi l'antidote au taux de
chômage des personnes handicapées
c'est l'entreprise adaptée qu'est ce
qu'une entreprise adaptée c'est une
entreprise dans lequel il y à peu près
80 % de personnes en situation de
handicap
mais c'est surtout une entreprise où les
postes de travail sont adaptés aux
restrictions des personnes c'est surtout
pour moi un lieu d'épanouissement
incroyable un antidote à la morosité
un antidote à l'individualisme et le
lieu d'un management adapté
comment je le sais et bien c'est grâce à
ce gilet que je porte ce soir ce gilet
c'est le symbole d'un challenge né d'une
rencontre il y a quatre ans j'ai été
recrutée au sein de deux entreprises
adaptées et j'ai rencontré florence une
de mes boss florence à mon arrivée
elle me détestaient sacré handicap alors
que nous devions travailler ensemble au
fil des mois nous nous sommes
apprivoisés et un soir j'ai reçu un
texto
non je n'ai pas bu j'attendais juste
d'avoir rencontré quelqu'un d'aussi
tarek mois pour lui proposer de
participer au rallye aïcha des gazelles
il m'a fallu deux secondes eni et ma
réponse fut oui
ah oui il faut que je vous dise florence
a survécu un avc en 2014
cette aventure au bout de nous mêmes que
nous avons préparé nous le savions nous
allions devoir nous adapter
l'une à l'autre florence d'ailleurs m'a
dit t'es complètement taré de me suivre
étant donné mais c'est qu'elle est bien
pourtant je peux vous jurer que j'ai
vécu l'aventuré humaine et sportive de
ma vie sachant que le sport et elle le
sait très bien c'est pas mon truc c'est
mon handicap à moi c'est nous avons fait
le choix de faire cette aventure c'est
que nous souhaitions faire comprendre
que le handicap n'est pas toujours
visible c'est aussi le projet de notre
entreprise adaptée je peux vous jurer
que rester 15 heures dans une voiture
par 45 degrés pendant huit jours avec
les séquelles de florence c'est juste du
grand n'importe quoi
nous avons parcouru 7500 km traversé des
oueds gravi des collines des dunes
nous avons affronté les tempêtes de
sable les nuits sans sommeil
tout ça en nous adaptant l'une à l'autre
par une belle matinée
nous nous sommes plantés vous mais quand
je vous dis planté s'est planté quatre
heures et demie en plein soleil dans les
dunes à pelleter pour sortir notre 4-4-2
là au bout de deux heures
j'ai tout arrêté j'ai dit moi maintenant
ça suffit vous allez me chercher un
hélico vous me sortez de là
immédiatement florence elle a continué à
creuser au bout de deux heures elle m'a
renversé une bouteille d'eau sur la tête
pour me faire taire en entreprise c'est
pareil on ne peut pas s'entendre avec
tous ses collègues
on doit gravir des collines montée des
dunes être obligé de changer de cap on
peut être amené à pelleter avec des
personnes différentes à nos côtés mais
comme je viens de vous le faire
comprendre c'est facile qu'on pense qui
s'arrêtent de pelleter en premier
tout est possible à partir du moment où
on prend en considération l'autre son
état de santé son handicap c'est
l'essence même de l'entreprise adaptée
c'est de comprendre comment fonctionne
l'autre de respecter les restrictions
intellectuelle physique de travailler
ensemble est arrivé un résultat humain
et économique
ce que je souhaite c'est que ces valeurs
de l'entreprise adaptée soit duplicable
dans l'entreprise classique au contact
de mes collègues en situation de
handicap à travers mon expérience et
entreprises adaptées aux côtés de
florence à travers ce rallye j'ai
inventé une terre interne l'économie
humaine
on adapte le travail à l'homme pas l'
inverse
alors je sais vous allez me dire oui
mais lente entreprises adaptées elles
ont des aides financières ou
effectivement mais elles ont aussi les
mêmes charges
les mêmes taxes le même impératif de
réussite que les autres entreprises et
je dirais même un interactif supérieur
puisque nous accompagnons des personnes
en situation de handicap ne devons les
faire progresser de manière à ce
qu'elles puissent éventuellement passer
de dans le monde
vie ordinaire pour moi cette expérience
le résultat le plus précieux en tant que
responsable commercial c'est que tous
les matins quand j'allais chercher du
business je savais que ce business
allait permettre à des personnes en
situation de handicap d'avoir un travail
et je peux vous jurer que c'est un
challenge pour les personnes en
situation de handicap de trouver et de
conserver un emploi
mon expérience au sein de ces
entreprises adaptées m'ont obligé à
sortir de ma zone de confort m'ont
obligé à percevoir mon entourage
différemment et c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'extraordinaire
l'entreprise adaptée c'est un antidote à
la routine professionnelle
c'est un antidote à l'individualisme
c'est un antidote à la morosité l'humour
et l'autodérision était mon quotidien
à côté de ces personnes
exceptionnellement à part si j'ai choisi
ce soir de vous parler de ce modèle
économique certes pas novateur mais peu
connu c'est que je veux que vous tous
ici
quel que soit votre structure à partir
de demain vous ouvriez votre coeur et
votre esprit que lorsque vous allez
recevoir un cv d'une personne en
situation de handicap
vous allez l'étudier et qu'à compétences
égales vous donnerez la personne la
chance à cette personne je veux
également que vous remettiez un peu de
bonne humeur et d'optimiste dans les
entreprises les associations les
collectivités et que surtout l'humain
reprenne sa place dans notre monde si
vous faites tout ça alors je rémy ma
petite pierre à l'édifice
aïe aveux de gym je pique cette phrase
au fabuleux martin luther king pour
conclure et vous dire que mon rêve à moi
c'est que demain il n'y plus besoin de
loi pour faciliter l'insertion des
personnes en situation de handicap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]